When you orbit the camera around something, the target's fixed and only the
position changes. When you turn the camera to the left, you're fixed in
position and the target changes. When you're zooming in you're not doing any
kind of change because you're just changing the field of view. When you pan
you're moving the camera perpendicular to the way it's facing, so both the
target and position change. In fact, controlling where the target location is
can be a somewhat frustrating part of using various graphics modelers. If you
pan and then orbit, you're now orbiting around some different target location,
which may not have been what was intended. Note that I didn't ask about the
effect of dulling in the target in position. Dolly certainly changes the
position, but it's up to the program whether to change the target in this case.
If the control also moves the target, it's likely you're walking forward and
don't particularly care where the target is located. If the target doesn't
change, it's like you're walking towards and object and perhaps slow down as
you approach it.